[Music]
all right
we are now live for the ama
for september uh 2020 hard to believe
that we're here
in september already
but there it is so it looks like i've
got a lot of questions already
lined up so i'll just jump right into
them i will say however
keep in mind that if you're asking
questions that people have asked many
many times before like what do you think
about jordan peterson or g-jack
probably going to skip over those
because i've sort of done those to death
all right john says he's got a question
about martin luther somebody i haven't
read for for years quite frankly
how do you construe the martin luther
quote about sinning boldly is he saying
that justice is of no importance
of all in this world well i can't
actually answer that at least i'm just
moving some papers here he's not saying
sin boldly all the time
he's saying that that's what you do when
the chips are down and and you've gone
through everything else
justice is obviously important in the
world as are other things that would
would guide our actions or our beliefs
or behavior or stuff like that so
um you know that's
that's probably enough about that i i
mean they could make a broader
statement about moral theories in
general
that a lot of times the thing the
catchphrases that people associate with
them they're part of a much much larger
system and so they they have more
meaning within that system and
applicability
all right uh jd sword asks if i've read
philadel's on anger yes indeed i have
as a matter of fact i referenced uh
that back when i was still in new york
and i was doing um i was doing my series
on anger called
understanding anger there's a whole
playlist of those and i talked about the
epicureans
and obviously epicurus i mean he might
have said a lot but we we have very few
of his texts unfortunately so we don't
really know
everything that you know epicurus
himself had to say
let alone guys like matt doris who would
be kind of cool to have as well
um so we're in large respect rely on
philadelphia
anger which unfortunately
is one of those texts from herculaneo
it's one that got enrolled and a bit
damaged so we don't have
full text we do have some other things
um that are that are
useful from philodama where he's talking
about anger like his
discussion of um frank speaking parisia
in greek where he talks about whether
you should talk
harshly to students or not you know um
so yeah i've read quite interesting he
makes a distinction between
natural anger and then anger that's
motivated by what the epicureans called
vein desires and pleasures uh kenos
you know empty so a lot of the things
people do get worked up about and upset
about
not really worth getting that upset
about it
um jonathan question that's been on my
mind for a long time
is how might you reconcile the stoic
concept of logos with a heidigarian
ontology
i don't think you would i don't think
you'd reconcile anybody with a high
targaryen ontology because heidegger is
very clear
that everybody else's ontologies prior
to him
are misunderstandings of the question of
being
so you're not going to reconcile those
together that's sort of like saying
you know how can you put a log of fi you
know log into the fire
and reconcile the log in the fire well
either the fire is going to go out or
the log's going to get burnt up
so you're not going to reconcile them in
the sense of having some sort of
you know fusion of them could you bring
in some heidigarian
insights into stoicism yeah
possibly you know um they're probably
going to be at significant odds over
you know the theory of emotion and
mighty girls moves so you're
going to get a lot of traction there um
but you know you may find some things
where you can have at least some
bringing things together but
reconciliation is just not going to be
unless you mean something very different
by reconciliation that's not really
going to be
possible uh joshua do you happen to have
any book recommendations for someone
interested in learning about critical
race theory well i mean charles mills
the racial contract is
a great place to start um
you know reading martin luther king
besides reading how the i have a dream
speech which everybody brings
up but only actually reads a little bit
of and actually reading the letter from
a birmingham jail there's already an
important analysis about how racism
works and how it's against the natural
law
in there there's there's so many other
texts that you could go through so i i
i'm not you know i'm not sort of an
expert on that area maybe somebody else
would chime in
about that um but
yeah i mean it's important to like read
back i would say
the whole discipline of what we call
african-american philosophy
is something that we'd want to look at
so you'd actually read frederick
douglass
you know and when i say read i mean
don't just read a piece by
these people as representative read into
their um
their corpus martin luther king for
example the more you read of him the
more you realize that he's not this
sanitized version of let's be nice to
each other that so many
people today would like him to be which
was you know
uh very different than what he was being
portrayed as
in the past and that his you know his
analyses of what was going on were
actually quite quite deep
so i would say reading deeply is the key
there
um a says which country do you think is
the best politically and which one do
you think could
realistically serve as a model for the
us assuming you're dissatisfied with the
current state of affairs in the us
i don't see why anyone wouldn't be
dissatisfied with the current state of
affairs in the u.s
given what a shambles it is and what a
mess it's been for
years and years and years you know
i mean i don't think that you can
actually get many
i don't think you can get americans to
to look at other countries as really
being a satisfactory model
i would hope that you know we could
instead of like talking about individual
countries we could talk about the fact
that
for example most developed countries
have
good working systems of public health
care that may have some problems with
them you might not get every drug you
want
there might be rationing but there sure
is held better than what we've got here
you know except for the rich or the very
lucky
so in that case you wouldn't be
comparing directly country to country
you'd say
listen it's sort of like talking to like
your idiot friend
who doesn't um think that they should
wear pants
in in the winter and you're like listen
everybody else on the block
is wearing pants not only are they
helpful for keeping
you know uh the snow out of your crotch
but
um you know they look nice and you can
put things in the pockets don't you see
how all these other people
and you know your idiot friend could be
like i'm still i'm you know liberty i'm
going to do what i want to do
you'd be like well you're an idiot you
know at some point you have to you have
to do that
there's a lot of things where we we
could
change for the better by emulating other
countries
it's going to be very challenging to do
so because many of the things where we
need changes
for example in education care policing
these things are handled so much at
local levels
and the local levels have too much
autonomy
and the the processes are incredibly
politicized when it comes to any sort of
issue like that
and we have a dysfunctional political
system deeply dysfunctional
um so i don't know that um we can do
that
which country do i think is the best
politically i mean
i wouldn't be able to say i could see
that there are countries where
the social systems seem to work better
and where there's less of this let's
burn it all down if we don't get our way
if it's [ __ ] going on um where
there's there's uh some understanding
that we do
have to all live together and we have to
start working on and solving our
problems
um we can say that there's political
systems that work better than ours like
our electoral college thing is
is a crazy mess that we'll never be able
to get rid of
because to get rid of it would require
constitutional change and we can't do
that when democrats and republicans
basically can't even like sit in the
same place without without
hating each other so i don't see much
much progress happening there
all right i'm going to take one question
by kierkegaardian dude
and i'm going to try to take you know
generally just one
one particular question by a person and
then move on to people who haven't had a
question answered
so i'm not really interested in the
general
kierkegaard critique of hegel that's a
little bit too sweeping
do i think nietzsche is the most
important philosopher to read when it
comes to understanding the dilemma of
contemporary meta ethics
um so i'm gonna go on a little bit of a
rant here
meta ethics is [ __ ] um it's a
discipline that was invented
and people get a lot of mileage out of
it but
it's not really if that's really a
separate field from normative moral
theories
every time that you look at a real
normative moral theory and you do more
than read the wikipedia article on it or
go beyond just a textbook version of it
like say aristotelian virtue ethics a
tradition that goes all the way down to
the present
with you know proponents like aleister
mcintyre
they are already encompassing meta
ethics because meta ethics
you know doesn't just you know have to
do with like the the the things that we
place under the wikipedia entry
it has to do with how do you understand
your moral theory
in relation to other moral theories how
do you frame how do you sort of frame
moral development and all that sort of
stuff and every main
moral theory has a meta ethics so the
field of meta ethics
i think is kind of bs every one of the
things that we talk about is being meta
ethics
like you know emotivism emotivism is
also a moral theory i mean
when you read the classic literature of
it you know like stevenson for example
it's clear isabel he comes out and tells
you that
so so there's that issue right meta
ethics
and and normative ethics not really
separate from each other people just
like to
pretend that they are because they they
get something out of that when they
really interfuse with each other
um is nietzsche the most important
person to read
no i wouldn't say so i'd say he's he's
an important person to read
um you know but he doesn't have the
answers to everything
i think all of you know i'm a pluralist
so
i don't have anyone who i see as like
the
single philosopher to go to for for
stuff
so all right
mike finney what do you think about
shunning authors books after finding out
they were or are pretty horrible like
some old sci-fi
authors or racists or jk rowling with
her comments about trans people
well to begin with angle is two separate
things right so i wouldn't lump those
together
under the same thing um if we're talking
about you know like old sci-fi authors
who are racist
like um you know not a sci-fi author as
such but i guess you could call them
such like lovecraft horror author weird
tales
author you've got a couple choices there
you could say well we're not going to
read them because he was a racist and i
don't want to read those things
and there you've got to talk about a
difference right you can say
i'm not going to read them but i'm not
going to like compel anybody else not to
read them and that's perfectly fine
you cannot read anybody that you like
i'm not reading
like a million different authors right
now as i'm talking to you
right and nobody gives a gives a damn
about that right
because i'm not going out there and
saying i'm not going to read hp
lovecraft you know or
whoever when you try to make it a thing
like let's ban
h.p lovecraft's books which i don't see
anybody doing
i do see some people saying oh you
shouldn't reference him or read him
um that's when we get into the territory
where you can say
i don't know you know there could be so
there i i would say there's valuable
circumstances under which you would read
that
for example if you're actually going to
do critique of it you have to read it
and reference it
right you can't just like push it to the
side um but you might also say well
you know there's ways in which we can
look at the racism and say that i'm not
going to let that bother me
or it's not really that essential to the
story i mean as somebody
of on my mother's side french canadian
descent
lovecraft would be somebody who you know
thought of my race as being a bunch of
uh
degenerates right they were moving down
into new england
from quebec and he didn't like that
right um any more than he liked the
portuguese being there or the italians
or
or let you know not to mention other
worse races right
um you know you have a choice about that
jk rawlings
present day right uh i don't think we
would say that
you know jk rawlings is totally unaware
of what's going on
in the way that lovecraft might have
been about issues of gender and
sexuality
so the she's probably got a higher
burden we can also add the fact that her
books suck
i don't i don't i've read the i read the
first harry potter book and i was like
because
you know i was like what is everybody
getting out of this and i was like man
this
i see why people like glom on to this
but it's not very good
um compared to other fantasy authors
that were around at the time i mean
compare her stuff to ursula kayla
green's
wizard of earthy stuff no comparison
you know um and so you know i don't
think that we have to worry too much
about jk rowling she's doing quite fine
she's got lots of sales
she should be set for life so
if people want to not read her books i
would say don't read them because
they're not particularly good stuff
but let's say her books actually were
really good
and she wanted to make you know remarks
about trans people
that might turn people off and i think
that's fine i i think you know
why why are we so upset about people
saying i prefer not to read this
it's only when people are like
organizing and saying let's burn the
books
ban the books you know uh boycott the
publisher don't read anybody else's
books coming from that publisher
you know where i think we have problems
and and we have to make distinctions
about this
this whole cancel culture thing it's
like a huge stamp and it means
all these different things to different
people we got to be careful
in the way that we're thinking about
these things
all right um let's see what else we got
here
just skipped a little bit um
chris any advice on bringing up
philosophical
concepts in conversation without making
it sound like philosophy
okay so i actually do this when i do
like workshops with business people
i present them with ideas and i tell
them that you know these are ideas that
actually work
and you know they can learn more about
it if they want to they don't know that
the ideas are coming from aristotle or
the stoics or thomas aquinas or
things like that if they ask me
afterwards i'll let them know and i'll
say well i mean
this this is a this idea about anger is
dealing with the difficult good
that i've been talking about for the
last hour that came from thomas aquinas
you might check him out you know that's
that's one way to do it i think is the
conceal the fact that it's actually
philosophy
um what other ways could you do it
i mean that's really the big one you
could you could talk about like
the historical period that they're
involved in and then you know name drop
them
into it um i i don't really know much
beyond that
most of the people that i've you know
i'll say too most people that i'm
interacting with these days
either they're like people who don't
care at all about philosophy because
they're like my family
and some of my friends and we just want
to hang out and sort of like turn our
brains off for a bit
and do other things and talk about like
you know who's who's now
pregnant and who had a kid and you know
who's going to school where
and you know who got sick and stuff like
that or
reminisce about the old days or i'm i'm
being brought in to talk about
philosophy so i'm actually not a really
good
person to talk about that because a lot
of people who are engaging with me do
want to talk about philosophy right
all right uh lyle himself why is
the american mainstream less so out of
touch with the masses
i don't think that it is i think that's
that's kind of a
a talking point that people on the right
have
i see no i see no evidence that that
people on the
mainstream left are out of touch with
the masses any more than people on the
mainstream
right are um it depends on which person
you're talking about people who are in
the political class and are making tons
of money
like barack obama or nancy pelosi
who are pretty center left um they're
not radically left
um they they're out of touch but they're
out of touch not by being leftist
they're out of touch by being rich and
powerful just like people who are on the
right
are out of touch by being rich and
powerful
you leave behind your humble beginnings
as you may compromise
after compromise after compromise that's
not a left dynamic that's a rich person
dynamic
there's plenty of other people on the
left who aren't out of touch with that
um
i you know i know funny so that's kind
of a
kind of it's sort of a non-starter
premise to ask about
um all right
vishnu asks hi how are you very nice to
ask
i am very busy i am teaching
six classes this semester and there's a
long story about how i
wound up doing six when i really only
meant to do four
but i'm committed to it so that means
that i'm shooting videos i actually just
thought
shot three videos this morning for my
biomedical ethics class
at carthage college that i'm teaching
which i was asked to teach starting you
know
in july they contacted me and they're
like hey can you do this and i
may be foolishly committed to doing it
so i'm
pretty busy you know i still have my
usual clients
and consulting work that i'm doing
and i've even picked up a few new
clients as well
we're gearing up for uh stoicon
for which i'm going to be a backup
speaker
stoic week and stoic on x's
as editor of stoicism today i have to
you know
be involved in the promoting and stuff
like that
so a lot of
work going on my daughter just moved up
to
attend school here at university of
wisconsin-milwaukee
so we're trying to find time to actually
spend time together socially distanced
we've been able to meet up once my wife
is just as busy as i
am she's working downstairs right now so
we're both super super busy
and trying to you know trying to live a
life together
uh and do a few fun things on the side
every once in a while go take a walk
together
or have you know like the heavy metal
philosophy the heavy classic heavy metal
class you know or
things along those lines um but yeah i
am
really busy probably in better health
than i've been
in years uh in part because of all those
masked up
walks which is which is a good thing
eating well
so that's uh yeah that's what's going on
bindi bush pig my supervisor said
rationalists were fundamentally
atheists but i always view them as
theists though that's a large group
it is a large group so who are we
talking about as rationalists if we mean
the continental rationalist descartes
was a theist you can't
cartesian philosophy there are arguments
for the existence of god now you could
say like pascal does that
descartes brings in god to like get his
philosophy off the ground and then
doesn't have any use for him and and we
know that descartes was not a
particularly committed religious
believer
but um god still plays a central role
spinoza is a rationalist
god is substance leibniz is a
rationalist so
maybe your advice your supervisor means
rationalist in a different sense because
if he's talking about historically the
people that we call philosophical
rationalists
very clearly uh some of them are are
theists
um they be
maybe more deistic than other
you know sort of um more robust theists
you could say but they they are
definitely theists
if we're talking about in say the 20th
century
and we're talking about rationalism in
french circles then yeah they would
typically be
atheists although they they often like
you know leon brunchfig
believed in some sort of conception of
spirit that's rather
rather a lot like foyer box conception
um and his his discussions about
christianity that is really the the
religious community of humanity so it
depends on which rationalists you're
talking about
uh nicholas are there theories of
natural philosophy that are neither
aristotelian thomas teleology and
nietzsche and perspectiveism i'm
interested in its reference ethics yeah
there's tons
i mean you're just talking about
rationalists descartes has a philosophy
of nature there's
all sorts of uh you know philosophies of
nature out there that aren't
either aristotelian or or nation i guess
you're prob maybe you're taking this
from mcintyre
from sort of a a uh you know thing
coming from
after virtue he's not really talking
there about
theories of natural philosophy he's
talking more about moral philosophy than
natural philosophy
where it's like aristotle or nietzsche
but yeah there's lots of different uh
perspectives and natural philosophy out
there
tea or coffee from david uh coffee i
drink coffee from the morning
until usually about four o'clock in the
afternoon
and then if i'm gonna drink anything i
switch to oolong tea after that i have a
massive uh thing of iron goddess of
mercy that we bought
about a year ago and i'm working my way
through
and then we get our coffee from stone
creek which is a local roaster
that does a lot of really great work
both with the
their supply chain they they do suspen
sustainable practices
um they're they're an ethical company
and they're they're
you know they're pretty good although
you know there's some complaints among
workers
obviously but they're they're probably
one of the best places to be
a barista around they offer all sorts of
cool classes when we're not in covid
times
so yeah this is stone creek coffee and
putting in a little plug for them all
right
useless projects is mersol from albert
kamu is the stranger the absurd hero the
whole way
through the book or just at the end no
there is no the absurd hero there are
absurd heroes if you read the myth of
sisyphus
there are many different ways to be a
to live out an absurd life and murseau
is just one of them and actually not the
best one camus
in one interview actually calls him kind
of a kind of a bastard
he's not endorsing marisol proper
response to the absurd as a matter of
fact there's some things kind of wrong
with mursal right
you look at his indifference to the
suffering of others
um and then you read kamu himself very
attuned to those sorts of things
um so you know i what i would do is is i
would you know read the stranger
obviously but also
read books like the plague and look at
some of the other characters and then
read the mythicist
sisyphus and that section about you know
an ethics of quantity and these
different things you know don juan could
be an
absurd hero for example um
sunny jim for a newcomer to nietzsche
what order do you read his works any
order you want
they don't have to be read in a
particular order i suppose you could say
you should start with the birth of
tragedy
you know because it's an early work and
it really is a good work that you
shouldn't avoid
you know nietzsche says some bad things
about it later on but you've got to take
that with a grain of salt
it really is a work worth reading but
there is no
order in which you have to read
nietzsche's works as a matter of fact
with most philosophers there isn't an
order in which you have to read their
works
you can pick and choose it's up to you
you're going to reread the stuff anyway
after you've read some stuff it's sort
of like with the platonic dialogues
which one do you have to start with
start by reading something and then you
know expect to re-read later on
you know obviously with the platonic
dialogues maybe don't start with the
republic or the laws because those
are giant texts and there's so much
going on there but
i i start you know when i have students
read nietzsche
i start sometimes with um genealogy of
morals sometimes i have them start with
less books zarathustra
sometimes i have beyond good and evil
um i've used truth and lies in an extra
moral sense
as a starting text they're all just fine
places to go
just don't expect to understand
everything that you read right away and
you know you're going to see references
back and forth within his text
same concepts coming up over and over
again
housekeeping do you like the ancient
historians like plutarch herodotus etc
um which one would you recommend to
start with yeah i like reading them i
like reading history
plutarch is way more than history
he's of importance to me more for his
moralia
the moral works that he wrote as a
representative of middle platonism
than he is for his historical works
because i'm a philosopher
um and i'm more interested in you know
the the ethical stuff that he's putting
forth
but you know this historical stuff is
fun to read i mean you could start with
herodotus
why not you know you can start with
thucydides if you want to
there's no set order in which you have
to read them you're not going to like
damage your brain by reading the first
one you know
the reading this one first and then
going on to another one
uh it's the same with philosophy right
you don't have to start with plato it's
just you know can be
awfully convenient to do that right you
could start by reading augustine
reading the confessions if you want to
there's no like absolute rule about
these sorts of things
um
mina says what are the what are the
western canon of literature what's the
best way to study it
that you want to google right because uh
the western canon of literature is this
vast set of books i'm not going to like
try to
list them off here there's disagreement
about which one should be in there
what's the best way to study it there is
no best way to study it different books
require different approaches
so reading for example boethius is the
consolation of philosophy
is going to require some of the same but
also some different
approaches than even just reading
augustine's confessions as i mentioned
right they're both
ones that are semi-biographical but
there's a lot of philosophical stuff in
there but yet there's also
you know differences between them um
so there there isn't any there's a lot
i'll say this
i'm going to do another little rant
there's a lot of people out there
selling like systems and approaches for
the great books
they're all full of crap i don't mean
like totally full of crap
because you know i'm sure you can learn
something from them but there isn't one
single approach that that works for
everybody there's no like
system or order that you have to read
them in those are for suckers
you know for people who want somebody
else to tell them what to do and they
think that
you know this person is going to provide
them with absolute guidance
that's that's not a good way to read
literature
you actually have to have some
you know independence and some
self-motivation
and you have to be willing to plug away
at these texts that are often not going
to reward you on the first
reading um and you know the people who
have like a set
you know orders they're selling
something to you they're not really
looking out for your best interest they
may think that they are because they've
deluded themselves
into this is the only right approach you
know
a lot of these great books programs i'm
really skeptical of them
and i've become more and more the older
i've gotten and the more and more that
i've interacted with people that are the
products of them who have these vast
gaps in their knowledge base
you know um so anyway
that's my little rant let me go on to
the next one
um
bradford can you comment on the
professor put on leave because of a
misunderstanding while giving class why
do you think the school went so far and
didn't take into consideration all
aspects
because people make decisions i mean
that you're you're asking me about some
case that i don't really
know more than you do about it um i
don't know
how how they arrived at the decision
that they made if you've ever been
inside the academy
you know you realize that it's not it's
never a place of like
absolute fairness and justice and due
process
sometimes that happens sometimes that
doesn't sometimes people
react to political pressure sometimes
they don't you know i don't know
um i wouldn't blow it up into a case
that's like representative of everything
that's happening in our society
i would treat it as the case that it is
and see if you find other cases
that are similar if you find enough that
there's a pattern then it's a then it's
really an issue
if not it's just some unfortunate
misunderstanding
that may be worked out legally you know
for all we know
um the personal you know the person's
not not going to be
doing terrible i'm sure they're going to
be on right wing talk shows and make
plenty of money doing interviews and
stuff like that
so um things like that will happen i i
you know when i taught for the first
time
i was in a intro to philosophy class
and i was a ta and my mentor garth
gillen
he wanted each of us to lecture twice
during the semester
and he would observe the lecture and
give us notes and that would
be helpful for us in our development and
this is like preparatory to like
having your own class later on so i get
up there and i gave a lecture
and and garth was somebody who did
holocaust studies so there was this this
piece that he
assigned for the day and it was about
like what was going on and the
humiliation of people and how it was a
deliberate
um thing to do and
um i i gave this lecture and this woman
came up to me afterwards she was an
undergraduate she's like
why did you say that you know the jews
hate god and i was like
what i didn't say anything remotely like
that and i made the mistake of like
having this this sort of you know where
are you getting this from kind of kind
of
you know in your face sort of thing with
her but i you know and i was
in the right because she was she clearly
misunderstood what was being
said and she hadn't done the reading and
all that and then she went and
complained to the chair
and the chair put you know brought me
into his office and he's like what's
going on here with this and i was like i
don't know this lady's
kind of nuts and she's saying these
things i didn't say
anything remotely like this in the
lecture i clarified that for her
afterwards
and clearly she didn't do the reading
and he's like yeah that's fine that's
fine
you got to learn how to deal with cases
like this where students are going to
not pay attention and they're going to
react more on the basis
of what's in their minds and weighing on
them
than anything to do with you so don't
you know don't take these things
personally don't
don't get angry at them for doing that
sort of thing just like adjust
and say here's what actually happened
and sometimes
uh that'll a lot of cases that'll
actually deal with the problem
uh some cases it won't and then maybe
you've got a kind of toxic environment
that you have to figure out what you're
going to do about so
all right uh bradley i'm lazy what is
the
or your source of ambition and
motivation
um well
i mean i'm lazy sometimes too you know
uh
i i set you know goals and and
to-do lists for myself and i don't get
everything done um
a lot of what i do is
because i've made commitments to do it
so you know i've got these six
classes i'm teaching this semester some
of them i could just
basically take the materials that i
already had for previous classes recycle
them
but i still have to like you know log in
engage with the students do the grading
all that that sort of stuff
some classes like biomedical ethics
um i'm you know developing all new
materials for that
and that's that's a bit more work or
world religions
i'm developing new materials i used to
teach it as a staple class but that was
before i
i became you know involved with
electronic
uh education and video so i don't have a
whole stock videos to use
so you know commitments to others and
following through on those commitments
is a big part of what i do
and then i would say that some of it is
kind of like you know you establish
habits and you know
uh those kind of see you through after a
while i i'm
i'm largely making it on on the basis of
inertia like every day
i get up and i'm like all right what do
i got to do i check my calendar
you know i sometimes rearrange things um
and you know i start plowing through the
stuff
and i take breaks from time to time you
know one of my
little luxuries is getting to take long
hot baths
and getting to read in the bath while i
do that or sometimes just zone out or
sometimes go on twitter and
you know see what's going on
and that you know self-care helps out
exercise can be very helpful if you're
not exercising
um you know it gets the circulatory
system going gets more
you know blood and oxygen in your brain
makes you feel a bit better
if you're feeling lazy and you make
yourself exercise you at least got
something done
that can help out as well
here's a good question from campar-82
is our only hope alien invasion or ai
takeover
um if those are our only hopes we're
really screwed
because what's to say that the aliens
wouldn't just look at us as
resources to be exploited right um
or the ai you know we could wind up in a
matrix
sort of thing so
i don't think so i mean i think things
are things are pretty
things are on a rough trajectory as far
as the environmental
degradation of the planet and
issues of justice and how we're dealing
with things politically
i don't know that the arc of history
actually tends towards
you know justice or anything like that i
i'm enough of a historian to say that's
that's not really the case
but there's always hope and we shouldn't
denigrate
the good that is here for us to
to enjoy and produce and realize in the
present
helping out my daughter with with you
know
lining up her studies and not being as
anxious about it as the typical freshman
that doesn't change the world situation
but
that is some good that a person can do
in in in this life
and it's not valueless because maybe
everything will go
go to hell in 70 years um
it still has value and so i don't think
we have to be hopeless um
all right bastian what is your take on
deodoma's role in plato's symposium and
plato's decision of teaching love
through the mouth of a woman
it's not just teaching love it's
teaching metaphysics it's teaching all
sorts of stuff
right um there might have actually been
a real woman deodoma we don't really
know about this
and again anybody this is one of those
things anybody who says that like there
definitely was no deodoma or we
definitely know
that there was a deodorant or deodorant
is definitely just a stand-in
for uh espasia who the consort of
pericles who who you know
might have taught socrates they don't
know we we don't know historically
um plato's you know plato's decision to
place it in the mouth of a woman
i mean plato plato says that women and
men have the same capacities
right there in the republic right so
plato's a feminist
in the sense of being an equality
feminist thinking that you judge people
not on the uh you know what's between
their legs but what they do in their
life and what's in their minds
um so you know
it may be a reflection of some some
actual historical thing
it may be a way of getting around
um you know the fact that all the women
have been dismissed
uh you notice that she talks about man
and man right
so um i don't really know
um what i do know is that it's
significant that there's this
this narrative shift um
nowhere man nietzsche's perspectivism
how is he
how does i guess how does he objectively
state the existence of order and rank
and emphasis
that philosophers not born and made
preordained meaning
contrast existentialism i don't really
know exactly what you're saying there
because that's kind of a word salad um
so i'm just going to pass on that one
all right
um thomas watson i'm
still only 17 and still not very well
read what philosophers would you
recommend for a beginner
but thai is one of the most intriguing
i've come across so far yeah but tai
is an intriguing guy his stuff is pretty
weird and wild
right and it's a lot of fun i don't know
that i would
i mean there's nothing wrong with
reading him but i don't know that i
would i would like have him
early on in my my studies um
then again i i you know i got into
philosophy
not reading things in the right way
myself and you know things have turned
out okay
um at 17 you probably
shouldn't be particularly well read as a
matter of fact you
you're probably not going to be so even
at uh 25
there's a lot of stuff out there to read
and you're going to keep going
at it i can't even say that i'm
particularly well read when i was in
graduate school
one of the backhanded compliments that
one of my friends
gave because there were people who'd
read a lot more stuff than me
was you know greg hasn't read much but
he sure gets a lot of mileage out of the
things that he's read because i was an
attentive reader
so you know he was saying this guy
doesn't read enough stuff now that
changed as i
got ready for my comps and prelims and
stuff like that
um but you know i wouldn't i wouldn't
worry too much about not being well read
i would
i would take this as a time to sort of
like you know stock up on things read
read things that people say are good
and you know um you don't have to read
them in a particular order
you don't have to be worried about that
what you're reading for class
if you if you do go to college and you
know like major in philosophy or take
philosophy classes
read that stuff but then read other
stuff too because we never get to put
all the books that we'd like into the
syllabus because we're stuck with this
15
week which is really often in a lot of
some of the places i'm teaching we
really only get 12
effective weeks of teaching in um
you always have to leave all this stuff
out that you'd like to to address
so you can read whatever you want to you
know um
yeah i think it's probably enough there
all right lala says happy weekend happy
weekend everybody else here
floriga says what do i think is the best
way to teach philosophy to high school
students without watering philosophical
concepts down
you're always going to water them down
it's not a question of whether you water
them down it's a question of
how you do it and whether you go too far
with it
so it's okay not to expect the world of
high school students i mean high school
is a time where you're like
figuring out your body and where you fit
into the
social classes and hierarchy and
dealing with all the the [ __ ] rules
that your school has for you
so i wouldn't put i wouldn't put too
much stress on um
high school students you know if you can
get across
some concepts and you know think about
this way
your goal is not to try to get as much
crammed into their head
sort of like stuffing a suitcase you
know like when you go on a trip
and you want to take all these things
along with you stuffing that suitcase
and then zipping it up
so that when you get there it like pops
open and everything's flying
is it's not that you want to make them
into lifelong learners
so you want to one part of this is
affective you want them to
not necessarily fall in love with ideas
but at least see that there's something
there that's valuable that is worth
going back to
over and over again you also want to cue
them into
what the resources are out there that
they can
keep on using to
you know continually learn to learn more
and more
and develop more and more as
junior philosophers right
so you know these days obviously that
includes the internet
so cueing them into um
places where they can get texts and read
them for free
um good podcasts good good video series
um useful websites things like that make
those part of your class resources
and then you know teach them in in class
you know
but but don't expect the world from them
i would say
all right uh
chris says can the stoics teach us
anything about our own times
lots of stuff you know for example
they can teach you that a lot of the
things that people are worked up about
are probably not worth being worked up
about and
how to avoid getting you know tangled up
with
you know a lot of different movements
and the rage that fuels them
um they can tell you that
when it comes to our political situation
um justice ought to be
really much more important than it is um
and that we ought to take principled
stands that you know
um the dichotomy of control didn't
keep stoics from actually taking um
committed sometimes for them fateful
stands on who should be in charge and
how we should treat people
there's a lot of things for them to
teach us so yeah i know you can say the
same thing about other forms of virtue
ethics too whether it's
you know aristotelian or various
christian
thinkers who also by the way use plato
and aristotle and the stoics
or the platonic tradition which isn't
just plato but also includes plutarch
and you know the neoplatonists yeah they
can all
they can all teach us things that are
useful
bradford gerst liberty versus equality
irreconcilable when you put it in such
an abstract way
i wouldn't even say you can say anything
meaningful about that
you have to specify what you mean by
liberty and you have to specify what you
mean by equality and where they
conflict with each other this this sort
of like slogan
level stuff just it's not not useful
uh mr big weekny my professor told me
aquinas believed christianity could
provide insights that philosophy could
not
what insights could he have had in mind
uh you know the
doctrine of the atonement for example
and the incarnation
um you know there's there's all sorts of
things philosophy
or rather theology that you know if you
look at the summation right
reason can provide the preambles of
faith
but it can't provide everything of the
faith there's there's a role for
things being revealed although there's a
lot aquinas
thinks there's an awful lot we can
figure out
through using human reason um but it's
usually a sort of dynamic you know faith
suggests something
reason takes it on thinks about it and
then comes up with
a you know a viewpoint on it right some
insights about it
um boys is how much how much have you
read about marx's critique of german
idealism specifically hegel
49 of it i don't know i mean i've read
quite a bit of marks
over the course of my studies you know i
i don't know exactly
um how much i would say
probably most of the stuff if we're
talking about the early philosophical
and economic manuscripts um
so you know yeah that
probably answers the question
housekeeping what do i think of erasmus
is somebody who's i remember enjoying
reading i haven't read them for so long
that there's really not much to say
he's somebody i'd like to go back to if
i ever do find the time
i recall there being stuff in there that
was
interesting but i can't really remember
what it was
so uh nick wood
thanks for all your work well you're
very welcome
glad to be doing it steve lebowski
what do i usually eat for breakfast
thanks for everything so i
you could say there's there's four main
kinds of breakfasts that i have
one is uh granola
and half and half um
we we don't have milk we have half and
half i've gotten used to using that
higher fat content and there's some good
granolas that we get
i am trying to do you know lower carb
but but you know i really do love
granola
so that's something uh smoothies are
another thing i'll have for breakfast
um take one of those like protein drink
things that we we get from costco and
then put in some some fruit and some
greek yogurt and sometimes things like
flax seeds or
some other high protein thing
hemp hearts right blend it all up
together eat it
um then there's you know occasionally
eggs and something else right it could
be
bacon it could be sausage it could be
smoked salmon
sometimes it make the eggs as omelets
with you know cheese
and peppers and if we have ham i use ham
or onions or things like that sometimes
i just kind of blend it in there
sometimes it's just eggs and cheese
sometimes it's egg sandwiches so a lot
of egg egg things
and then very very very occasionally
we'll have like a
you know like a full brunch but i
haven't done that for a long time we
haven't we haven't been
out to eat anywhere since covid uh
but every once in a while we'll do
something like like that oh and
sometimes we'll have pancakes too you
know or or waffles so
yeah all right govind uh cowshink
um have you read anything by marie
maurice blancho
what do you think of his works i haven't
read anything by him for over two
decades
so people recommended me to read him
because i was very interested in darida
i don't remember finding bla's show all
that insightful or interesting
so i i just haven't you know done it
afterwards
neolib shield why is it so hard reading
into to start reading into philosophy
i've tried picked up many books
including secondary lit even with the
most basic things i can't understand
anything and i get lost in the terms
i don't know um that is not the
experience that i would say
most people have had but it does happen
you know
maybe you're maybe you need to do it in
smaller chunks
and go back over it different people
respond
differently to philosophical literature
some people get more out of it than
others
it could help you to sort of map things
out make use of resources other than
secondary lit
so that that might help you out all
right
lord roku i've been reading through a
lot of stoic literature
i've been asking myself how epistemology
logic and physics tie in together into
ethics could you perhaps explain that so
the stoics didn't have the term
epistemology that actually fits into
what they call logic which has to do
with
processes of inference and particularly
with what they call
ascent so they have three main divisions
of philosophy and they weren't the only
to to do this
but they they really haul made it a
hallmark there's ethics
which also includes um some of what we
would call philosophical psychology
particularly
theory of the emotions although that
also fits into physics
there's physics which is about the
natural world and how it works
the reason why i say that psychology
would kind of fit into physics you know
if you think about aristotle's on the
soul that was considered a physical work
so the stoics coming a little bit later
their stuff could fit in there as well
and then we have
the logic which is you know not just
about argument
it's about how we make inferences you
know what counts as good inferences
and the epistemology kind of figures
into to that
and there are three different
disciplines but obviously they're
connected with each other you know if
you read epictetus
there's a really funny section
where he's talking about why the art of
reasoning
is important he's talking about logic
there this is in book one
of the discourses and he must have had a
student who was like i don't want to
study this logic stuff i just want to do
the ethics and he's like
fine do whatever the hell you want you
know see how that works out for you
you know um just study the ethics stuff
and then when somebody trips you up with
some
some sophistic argument don't come
crying to me
go to the logic books and start studying
dummy
and epictetus is very content to do this
with a lot of things to say
hey man you want to do things your your
own different way because you think
you're smarter than everybody else
you go right on ahead and see how it
works out for you so you know the logic
part
helps us with the ethics in
structuring our our moral you know and
practical
reasoning about things and the physics
thing helps to understand the nature of
the universe if you want to be
living in accordance with nature you
have to have some conception of what
nature
looks like right now unfortunately we've
lost
probably 90 percent of the classic stoic
literature
we look at the list of books in in uh
diogenes liertes
and we have almost just nothing from
zeno nothing from clianthus nothing from
precipice
nothing from uh diogenes uh nothing from
you know these other authors just
just fragments here and there preserved
in galen
or plutarch or cicero or people like
that
so we don't we don't know enough about
we know more about the ethics than we do
about their their logic or their physics
but
you know we we we do know some of it
all right uh constantine do you feel
philosophy helping you in daily life if
so it should be
should it be taught at school yeah
obviously i feel philosophy helping me
in my daily life
it provides me with a living a source of
income
that's kind of trivial but yeah it's
helped me a lot you know in a lot of
ways
but i'm kind of a weird case right so to
begin with
i'm somebody who's studying philosophy
professionally for the last 30 years
so you know it could be something that
has nothing to do with my life like i
could be
like you know some some analytic
philosophers where they do their little
thing and then there's the rest of their
life over here and i've always found
people like that rather odd ducks
because i'm i got into philosophy in
part because i wanted it to be practical
and have something to say about life and
how to live it but you know that makes
me
kind of in a minority would it be better
to teach it
in in school yeah
it would be but you know the way
our systems are set up there's not a lot
of room for that unfortunately
they're pretty um pretty stuck
you know
when when when we have trouble finding
funding for
physical education and music and art
it's going to be hard to produce an
argument for philosophy
classes but we can try to do our best to
smuggle it in
you know caesar augustus who is the
most misrepresented or misquoted
philosopher
i don't know how we would ever figure
that out
i mean we'd have to like have a way of
like comparing the things that are
said to what what they actually did say
i i guess i could just say there's a lot
of people
who do get misquoted
[Music]
and we got to be kind of you know if you
don't see where the quote is actually
coming from
you should probably assume that it's
[ __ ] you know especially if it's got
a picture of the person and especially
if they get the picture wrong
like if they're quoting epictetus on
some stoic thing
like in the stoic facebook group and
it's a picture of epicurus
you know this person is full of crap
because they they can't tell the
difference
between the two of them and they're
probably trying to sell you some
coaching
thing or some bs like that
all right um james
what do i think are reasonable critiques
of mills harm principle and
individualism more broadly
i mean a lot of the criticisms of
individualism are just not looking
you know it's sort of a superficial uh
treatment of things
very often the individual is much more
abstract and they look they don't look
at their
relationships people can be in sort of a
privileged position to be
individuals and then they forget about
everything they're getting from
everybody else
nobody's self-made you know the harm
principle is the idea that we shouldn't
forbid any actions usually sometimes
it's only governmental sometimes we
think about larger social stuff
we shouldn't forbid actions that unless
they harm other people
so if if somebody's harming themselves
and they're only harming themselves
we should let them do that so if they
want to you know if they want a small
crack
or shoot up heroin
according to the harm principle
understood in a certain way
then they're not really hurting anybody
let them do it
now of course you can say yeah but
junkies steal stuff you know to feed
their habit
well then they are hurting somebody else
right so there's a lot of cases where
the harm principle seems to apply
it doesn't really apply when we think
about the consequences
a parent who's getting getting high and
wasting their resources on that
um you know they're neglecting their
children they're neglecting certain
duties and so that would be a problem
all right uh govind are you interested
in indian philosophy and works like the
upanishads or
uh nagarjuna's works i am interested in
it
i i'm handicapped by the fact that i
don't read sanskrit
if i want to go you know i have to trust
other people's translations
and it's not an area of my
specialization i've read enough
in indian philosophy and also chinese
philosophy to know that these are
vast cultural spheres as big as the west
and i will never
in my lifetime be able to be be able to
make enough progress
in them to be really an expert that said
you know i'll teach some of that stuff
to my students
i've taught uh non-western philosophy in
the past
i just i don't you know i don't
specialize in it and i don't get the
time to read as much as i would like
um life circle i'm reading nietzsche and
i have a question
when he talks about men in some texts is
he talking about men
or talking about the human being we'd
have to go to the the text and see
whether he's using mention
which is a generic term for a human
being which then gets translated as men
typically or whether he uses other terms
um so it would depend on on the
particular instance
lokesh aren't democratic societies close
to a collapse when our electoral
politics is quite simplistic
considering how complex our societies
are i wouldn't say that
i would say they're close to collapse
when
the different sides no longer think that
they can work with each other
and that we've we've had an erosion
of you could call it civil society
in terms of our politics for the last 20
years and
and both sides are equally responsible
for that although the conservatives
right now
are are doing way more damage than the
liberals are
at this point in time in america part of
why i'm against them
um because i take my my positions from a
virtue ethics perspective
um rather than from i'm a conservative
or a liberal perspective
when we have the sort of
factionalization and polarization that
we have
we're in really dangerous waters
aristotle would say that
you know just read politics book five
and you'll see
um some some problems but having you
know
simple slogans and stuff like that
to deal with complex uh issues not that
big of a deal because when you actually
get in office
then you're like holy crap these are
complex issues we better bring some
experts in and we better start you know
doing some
structuring so that that's not that big
of a deal
all right damon says happy derby day uh
aristotle taught me how to handicap
horse races
i i guess it must be derby day i don't
follow horses the only uh
um sports that i really pay any
attention to are nfl football
and um hockey occasionally we have an
ahl team here that we go
and watch and i'll we'll also you know i
haven't done it for years and years but
we'll go and watch roller derby as well
but i don't know anything about horse
races um
solid here's another one i'm gonna have
to punt on how do you believe philosophy
affects architecture
i don't know you know that's that's way
out of my
my wheel well um
matt tucker do you know any
existentialist compatibilist soft
determinist i mean i agree that we are
in a sense radically free but i can't
choose to break the laws of physics
it's not really about breaking laws of
physics um yeah i mean
read john paul sartre being in
nothingness he's got a whole
section devoted to this very problem of
determinism and freedom
so he's an example nicholas can you
explain aristotle's knowledge and the
types of knowledge
um i mean you could look in nick mccann
ethics
book book six and you'll find
five types of knowing i wouldn't call
them knowledge
because we usually translate epistam as
knowledge but then there's
techne craft you know or art
there's um phronesis practical wisdom
sophia which is wisdom and such noose
it's kind of it's hard to explain it get
translated as intuition these are all
different modes of
knowing things but you want to go to
nick mccain ethics book book um
six jb bell good to see you uh apologies
if you answer this but any good
consoling works on
forced solitude speaking of social
distancing
that's a good question um
forced solitude i mean
you could read boethius's consolation of
philosophy he's under house arrest and
he's
bemoaning how shitty the world is and
how he's been mistreated and he's kind
of in solitude
and then lady philosophy comes and tells
him
you know you're really being kind of a
whiner you're not living up to your
principles
i don't know that that would actually
make you happier but i certainly take
your mind off of things for a little
while
um what else um
i mean rilka talks about solitude and
you know actually his advice to a young
poet does to
does does discuss this guy he's writing
to this guy
who's a military officer who wants to be
a poet and talking about the solitude
that he's in not because of forced
social distancing but because he's
stationed way out
in the middle of nowhere that that could
be interesting
um nietzsche talks about solitude at
different places particularly in the
spokes arathustra
epictetus talks that he's got a whole
chapter on solitude
so that might be worth checking out um
and you know epictetus is good because
he says
what what makes solitude or being alone
bad for you it's the feeling like
you don't have resources to deal with
the things that you have to deal with
which could be the very feeling of
loneliness right
so yeah
all right um let's scroll down again
uriah there's so much division in the
world today how can one develop a
holistic understanding of the present
political and cultural situation in
order to develop a method of
for engaging with the world i don't know
that you need to do that
to engage with the world i think that
you can like look at
issues that you want to focus on and and
you know you don't have to come up with
like
the theory of everything to be able to
act appropriately
um so yeah
all right uh hey um
what do i think of the categories if
they're not apocryphal i don't know
anyone who thinks they're apocryphal or
about
as i'm sure you know there's a scholarly
debate whether it's ontological logical
or linguistical
it's all three it was an easy way to
resolve it
why do you have to make it logical or
linguistical why can't you say
for aristotle the categories actually
you know
are ways in which we talk about being
you know
i i'm more concerned with the fact that
it's a it's a tough text
to start um undergrad students out on
so andrew after many years of
philosophical study and teachings do you
have an idea or a set of principles we
could use for daily life
yeah i mean i combined i combine a lot
of different
uh things together you know i draw some
from
stoicism and some from you know the
aristotelian approaches
um i'm a big fan of cicero and sort of a
ciceronian
eclectic uh i mentioned the platonic
stuff there's stuff from christian
thought that i draw in existentialist
thought
uh dialectical thought and and i you
know
a lot of these things are sort of you
know while this situation calls for this
thing i don't have like
any of the really big um in every
situation you must do this it's a bit
more contextual
uh himanshu should we read primary
secondary philosophical texts
i'll put it to this way if you're not
reading primary philosophical texts you
might ask yourself why the hell are you
doing philosophy
in the first place why would you let's
take plato
why would you ever deprive yourself of
the opportunity to read
these texts that we're so fortunate to
still have given how much ancient
literature has been lost
and instead read so-and-so's take on
plato why
why would you want to do that it's sort
of like you know
if you can go to a concert and see
saxon right who are still touring
that well once colbin's over i mean uh
biff byford has
got to be almost 70 and and they still
rock right i've seen him
on stage why would why wouldn't you go
see saxon
instead of seeing some saxon tribute
band you know or or listen to somebody
uh doing a documentary on saxon why
wouldn't you actually like
do that i mean secondary literature can
be helpful
but it's secondary literature except for
the really good secondary literature
which becomes a primary literature of
its own you know
like when you read um kojev's
introduction to the reading of hegel
that's secondary literature
but it's also kojev who's worth reading
because he's interesting
in his own sake you know a guy who so
strongly believed in
this vision that he's getting from hegel
that it led to him being an eu
bureaucrat
that's an interesting guy right um
yeah i mean secondary literature is
there to help you that's that's the
point of it
or to you know explore some interesting
things
coming from that well here's a great
example so here's one of my textbooks
for my bioethics class right basics of
bioethics
and it's not bad it's not great
textbooks are you textbooks usually
range from totally bad and suck to don't
suck too much
and there's a lot of stuff in here where
it's drawing on secondary literature
and then there'll be like a bibliography
right and that's where
like if they're talking about virtue
ethics which these guys don't that much
and
tend to get wrong they'll actually
mention like aristotle's nick of mccain
ethics
read the nick of mccain ethics you want
to check that stuff out right so
all right um
bruno do i have any idea what
heideggerian ethics could be something
with sorghum
heidegger really resisted ethics he
thought that any sort of
ethical comportment or way of looking at
things is actually
sort of putting blinders on he makes
that very clear in being in time
but you could develop an ethics of
authenticity out of heidegger
but you could do so with other
existentialists i think as well
uh sv do you recommend any documentaries
for philosophy
i don't watch documentaries so no you
know
uh go uh let's see stephen warren
is there any philosopher who stands out
in your mind when it comes to the
principles of self-discipline and
control
no there's a lot of philosophers who
talk about
about those issues so there's nobody who
stands out
epistemic mind here's an interesting one
if you could meet any philosopher that
has ever lived who would it be
and why uh you know i'm a big fan of and
some of canterbury
he was a cool guy some people might not
consider him a philosopher depends on
how you
how narrowly you construe philosophy
he's
probably the person i've written the
most about in the course of my career
somebody who i really like as a person
i like his his writings and thinking
through them
and he appears to have been from the
stuff that people say a really cool guy
um and he lived through some
extraordinary times
dealing with those british kings you
know what a mess
so those normans
all right let's see find some others
that haven't been answered before
um
let's see
adam asks could you please recommend the
best book out there on
courage i don't know that there is a
book specifically on courage that i
would recommend
i would recommend that you read what
ancient philosophers and medieval
philosophers and modern philosophers
have had to say about courage
i don't think you should try to just
find one book about it um
you know you want to compare the
different ideas of it against each other
so uh john has a jordan peterson
question is is he some kind of
pseudo-philosopher
yeah i'd say that's probably the best
way to look at it you know
he's uh or i mean you could call him a
philosopher if you want to just the sort
of same way as we call iran to
philosopher
third rate at best you know
certainly has a lot of cultural
influence because people
love easy you know solutions and they
love people who have these sweeping
assertions about stuff
and don't do careful research um
but ultimately you know i mean whatever
you're gonna find that's useful
in you know peterson just as much as you
would in rand
you can find with less baggage somewhere
else so
yeah um i think you know years from now
where he'll be as little red as herbert
spencer is today you know
um
uriah says top three works of aesthetic
philosophy after
kant i don't know i mean hegel's
aesthetics maybe
i'm not i'm not an aesthetics person so
i i would someday like to actually do
the research necessary to
put together a class on aesthetics since
i teach at
a institute in milwaukee institute of
art and design but
that's not really an area of
specialization for me um
let's see here swapnil
i'm from india do you have any advice on
reading dostoyevsky undergraduate here
yeah i mean um
dostoevsky i i think that
that mikhail bakhtin is right in those
uh
problems of dostoevsky's poetics
bactinas by the way
somebody who i said that you know like
sometimes secondary literature turns
into primary literature
bach teen is a prime example of that
he's really a cool person to read
he says that dostoevsky is like
shakespeare
where none of the characters are
by themselves representing dostoevsky as
such but it's the
interplay between the characters and
their actions and their mindsets and
their
speeches that they give about their
their point of view
that um produces what we could call the
dostoyevskyan
idea so there's that part that said
you're going to find a lot of philosophy
being discussed within dostoyevsky in
the mouth of characters for example just
the other day i was shooting stuff
on ivan karamazov's
speech prior to giving his grand
inquisitor poem
uh his his treatment of the problem of
evil
you know that's not necessarily
dostoevsky himself speaking but the
characters
put forth philosophical ideas and they
put it forth in the way that say like
platonic literature
did where their life also reflects
these ideas um so that
that might be helpful i i don't know
uh john are modern ontological arguments
still considered effective arguments for
the existence of god do you think
i mean i think the modern ontological
arguments are mostly
you know uninteresting and kind of kind
of
a waste of my time um i like anselm's
ontological argument which actually runs
through the whole of the prosylogy and
it wasn't called an ontological argument
and that's very different than what
planting is going to do with it or even
what de carter spinoza did with it
you know it's not as if there's an
ontological argument that all others fit
into
it it really depends on the way it's
framed and all this logically perfect
or this this absolute perfect being or
stuff like that that's not what anselm
talked about he actually told ganilo i'm
not using this terminology
for a reason i'm using this terminology
instead
so i don't know are they considered
effective arguments depends on what you
mean by effective do they convince
people to believe in god
not usually i mean most people don't
believe in god because of apologetics
because they read some arguments
somewhere and they're like aha now i
believe in god it's
it's you know religious conversion and
belief is usually a whole network of
different things
connected up with each other because
we're complex people
spinoza asks why is it many people think
science is superseded philosophy
well i mean most of the people who
believe that have a very dim
hazy conception of what science is and
what philosophy is
and it's always easier to play around
with abstractions
and terms than it is to actually get
messy and dig into things
the more that you come to look at
science and and the sciences
and how they work the more you see that
philosophy is intrinsically
connected with it we can also add that
there's there's you know people who are
very smart in some respects but are also
kind of idiots in other
respects like um you know stephen
hawking
uh writing his books or neil degrasse
tyson
who again you know they have a very
reduced understanding of what philosophy
is and they're kind of
stupid in that respect because they
should know better and then they
pronounce about how science has solved
all these
these things you know a lot of people
doing neuroscience are doing a similar
sort of thing oh we solve the problem of
free will
and then you read their stuff and you're
like no you didn't
you don't have any you don't have a clue
about this this stuff you're just
you know you're really good at this
thing over here but you suck at
everything else
and so that that i mean there's my
there's my answer to why so many people
think science
has superseded philosophy uh
puri do i think that learning art say
drawing or composing music
is an ethically indifferent or
unnecessary pursuit i'm personally very
drawn to art but fear it might be just
for me alone
um that's one of the things you got to
kind of figure out by doing
you know if you
if you operate just on the basis of that
fear while you just won't decide to do
it you'll have regrets about doing your
art
try doing it and see what what the
experiment holds i'm willing to bet that
as you compare your art with others and
you get involved with others and there's
responses
you will find it's not just for you
alone
is it an ethically indifferent or
unnecessary pursuit is it
ethically indifferent it can be although
as mcintyre points out
most practices when you actually get
into them you're going to find that
there are some ethical dimensions to it
unnecessary i don't know
this is where you should read rilka's
letters to a young poet
if you if you look into yourself and you
find that you must
in this case write or produce art then
the answer is there for you if you find
out that you you don't have to
then i guess it is unnecessary for you
but a lot of that is a matter of
temperament
all right thomas watson um
thanks for response better than food uh
cliff sergeant who i believe you had a
chat with a lot while back has
introduced me to so many good books
good that's that's great yeah i uh
interac it's been a long time since i
interacted with with cliff
i'm not sure how many years have passed
i know i was at least living here
but but it's been a while i think he's
kind of he's still out there but i don't
know if he's still doing book reviews or
not
um let's see
navaneeth says how can you how do you
actively be in leisure according to
seneca and also put in work
how much work thinking rest and leisure
is needed for a good life
okay well then you gotta kind of figure
out the balance right
um and it probably depends on where you
are in life obviously if you're an
invalid
like nature was towards the end you know
of his writing time or
these terrible headaches and stuff like
that you can't get as much done
um but you know
i suppose you have to you have to
combine them and part of part of it
here's what i'll say
part of it is is not indulging in
what we can call [ __ ] fake leisure
so for example just lying on the couch
binge watching netflix all day long
during your time off that's not really
leisure it leaves you
it leaves you not feeling rested
afterwards and able to go
back to work and do things doing
exercise might actually
in some respects promote leisure better
than just sitting around so
it really depends on what the leisure is
going to
produce or provide for you i guess you
know
all right um
a couple questions here about aesthetics
again i don't have much to say about
aesthetics
um xeno do you what do you think of
flowery pros do you like simple pros
better i mean
i i like i don't think there's a choice
between flowery and simple i think
there's a
wide range of stuff in between and i
kind of like that i do like to see
rhetoric used effectively and i can
appreciate it for its own respect
i'm not interested in embellishment just
for its own sake
and i gotta say i'm not i'm not i'm not
a good reader of poetry
quite frankly so uh
g glasgow opinions on a rent did you
ever get into her i
i got into her and i i've stayed into
her rent i think is one of the great
20th
century philosophers so
i was really surprised to see when when
trump got elected
the origins of totalitarianism going off
the bookshelves because that is a thick
dense book the sort of stuff i like from
a rent but is
not everybody's taste right it's very
complex
it's very uh demanding and i think a lot
of people
bought it read a little bit of it and
put it on their bookshelf you know
i think a rent is actually a great
thinker
who is undervalued largely because of
being a woman because there is still
you know a need to bring to light women
philosophers in part because things have
been
so male dominated in weird ways
rob mcqueen i'm planning on applying to
graduate philosophy programs i don't
have a ba in philosophy and i've been
out of school for eight years
any suggestions on increasing my odds
for acceptance yes
address that in your cover letter
because
it's definitely going to be an issue
they will probably want you if you are
accepted to take some uh
400 level undergraduate classes in
philosophy
that they're not going to make other um
other graduate students take that was
what they did when i was at southern
illinois university we'd have people
with literature come in
you know in a lot of places they want to
see a writing sample
try to do a writing sample that's pretty
philosophical i would say
so there's not much else
you try to score good on the gre you
know one way that you can in fact
try to do better on the gre for places
that are taking it
they'll be like these logic puzzle books
that you can buy at supermarkets
work your way through those you know
because that'll that'll help
boost your score on the gre a lot of it
is is kind of up to
luck unfortunately all right
let's see
um uriah mark total rough do you prefer
to write in the morning or read in the
morning i mean i'd prefer to be able to
do either one
most most mornings i'm doing other
things like putting out fires
or shooting videos in part because of
the light
you know we have these these skylights
and the light streams in you can see a
little bit
of you know where the the thing is so i
can't shoot all day long
uh depending on whether it's sunny or
cloudy so mornings are good for that
um yeah
all right um
mark huffling do i think the structure
of democracy has been irrevocably torn
apart can we now be witnessing the
decline of the united states as we now
know
well i mean anything is possible right i
avoid
huge sweeping statements like that
myself because
uh usually they have to be highly
qualified the united states has been in
decline for
quite a while if you're thinking about
our political culture and about our
economy which is still one of the
largest in the world
but is incredibly unjust and
exploitative
and unsustainable and
you know our situation in the world has
this massive hyper power that's not
going to continue on for that much
longer we've been
spending way too much on our military
in order to have that and that's that's
just not a
a particularly good investment you know
we um we're gonna have to figure out how
to live in a much more
multi-polar world than than the one that
we're currently living in but i think
it'll happen
you know and people are just gonna have
to get used to
um dealing with things that other
countries have been dealing with for a
while
uh is the structure of democracy
irrevocably torn apart
no i mean i'll say that when we're like
living in an actual fascist regime
um which is which is a possibility
rather than
sort of a proto-fascist regime where we
uh
the trump administration really is right
now
um but it hasn't been
radically torn apart um we still have
you know democracy
at a variety of different levels so
all right uh two most ancient i know
you're quite fond of rilka who are some
other poets you enjoy reading well
i just said i don't appreciate poetry
the way that i sort of wish i would
so i don't i don't really read much
poetry um
and part of that is not having the time
to do it unfortunately
um i used to like reading you know old
old
french poetry um i used to read
bold lair quite a bit but it i really
haven't had much time
so all right we're getting close to the
the end so
i'm gonna skip down a little bit paul
says what's on your shirt looks dear
metal related
saxon the band right this is somebody
sent me this for my birthday
uh from the list that i had for my
birthday bash uh denim and leather
is sort of like you know the
prototypical heavy metal
uh uniform you could say and saxony
actually has a song called denim and
leather and an album
called denim and love leather so all
right
uh all right i'm just gonna grab a
couple
um things sort of do like a lightning
round you could say i'm gonna
just look down and see what's the most
recent
stuff um
rzz do you think ayn rian is
misunderstood she seems to be hated on
many university circles especially
philosophy students
yeah she's misunderstood and mostly
because she's often not
read by philosophy people although there
i've i've actually known people in
philosophy departments who were randians
um but once you do understand her you
see that she's not very good
so it's kind you know it's good all sort
of things you don't understand me like
oh you got to get to know me and then
you get to know me you're like yeah
you're you're a terrible person i don't
want to hang out with you
so yeah um
let's see here
um what are my thoughts on young do
religious images hold the great
importance of young claims
religious images do have great
importance i don't think that young i
i'm not a big
fan of young when it comes to his his
sort of system
or approach or stuff like that i do
enjoy reading him because he's a good
he's a good stylist
um here's a good question from jordan
trump just tweeted that he wants to ban
critical race theory will this have any
implications for aspiring philosophers
only if they they think that trump
matters at all i mean he's an idiot
and doesn't know what he's writing about
most of the time
um i mean
so he he tweets something not not a big
deal unless he actually
enacts some sort of policy he's he's
tweeting to his base
who hate critical race theory even
though none of them have actually done
any reading
in it or studied it they just you know
like listen to the people on the right
like you know
shapiro and crying it and you know it's
basically
a dog whistle for for them um
all right
[Music]
paul says kierkegaard is fundamentally a
provincial psychological study and
anxiety depression and religious
preoccupation why is he still red
because you're wrong about that you can
say that he is that
and yet more so i invite you to find out
the more
by re-reading and by thinking about it
and approaching it in a different way
um
got a couple minutes left uh eb
do i believe adorno is relevant today
not only are his readings of
kant and hegel thorough and under red
they're the source of his reading on
utopia not identity
adorno is really really tough reading
he's he's
i find him very rewarding but he's as
tough to read
as hegel is in many of his works he
makes you think so much about stuff
he's not directly applicable a lot of
the time but insights that he'll provide
you with
will will help out so he's worth reading
i've always find him very difficult to
do any writing about or or to teach
so yeah um
let's see here
um mr dharam padgy
can you give me some advice on pursuing
the life of an academic i've finished my
master's from india in sociology
i want to apply to a phd in the united
states
this is a terrible time to try to become
an academic uh
in many fields not only because you know
kovid has made so many things uncertain
but
the job market was terrible before
kovitz started
it has been pretty bad and getting worse
for the last 20 years
pretty much the entire time since i've
been you know working on my dissertation
um so i mean if you want to try it go
ahead
people are going to get jobs but you got
to realize that if you're coming here to
the united states
the majority of the positions that are
being offered are for adjuncts
no benefits fairly low pay
no job security so you know it's kind of
kind of up to you
whether you want to try to do that do i
have any advice on pursuing the life of
an
of an academic expect it to be hard
um i mean i'm in a very different kind
of position because i have my own
business
and then i have been teaching so long
and i'm in known quantity that i get
more work thrown at me than i can
actually successfully do
that is the opposite of most academics
most academics
you know one of the places that i i
teach currently
they fired 15 tenured professors over
the summer
in july just by closing their programs
and saying
we don't have any need for you anymore
so
that gives you an idea about the sort of
stuff that's going on it's a tough time
if you're going to be an academic
probably need to have some sort of side
gig
or exit strategy handy i would say
and that's just the that's the reality
we're in um
so here's here's a good question from
leonix i'll close on this i keep hearing
bad things about prospects and academia
is there any chance prospects could get
better in the next decade what would be
needed to cause this
we would have to have a fundamental
change um
about uh our priorities is that likely
to happen
is that likely to pervade itself into
the more than 2 000 different
higher educational institutions each of
which is its own little
universe that we have here in the united
states
odds are kind of low aren't they that's
not to say that things aren't
you know maybe better in other places
you know
england or scandinavia or france or
you know i'm i'm only talking about
american academia but that's that's the
way it is
tristan says just be the best you're not
going to be the best
there'll always be somebody who went to
the right school
and kissed up to the right person and
knows these contacts
and they'll get the job and probably the
best person won't
jb bell says i'd say about as likely as
universal basic income
at least in the united states yeah i
mean the universal basic income could be
enacted on a federal level
you're not going to change american
education
on a federal level it would have to
change through all these institutions
and so it's it's it's uh it's probably
not going to happen
so you know maybe you want to look at
teaching
in other countries and see what
prospects are
in uh europe or things like that
so all right so that's that's a good
thing to close on
um oh actually let me close on this one
is there a song or an artist you love
but are afraid to admit it i'm a metal
head who likes
wap by cardi b for instance
so i'm a metal head you can tell just by
looking at this
and i'm also a big duran duran fan
you know and have been since since i was
quite young
i remember actually when i was in
graduate school
this uh this person who was living in
our dorm coming in
and looking at my stacks of cds and she
was like you like that stuff
and and like her her attitude about me
changed at that point
because i think she thought that i was
only into like metal and grunge and
you know the heavy stuff um yeah i mean
i was just talking the other day about
how rio is a really
wonderful song i don't think you would
expect that of the heavy metal
philosopher
but you know there it is um some other
artists who
you might be surprised i really like liz
fair
john cougar mellon camp before he went
nuts um
[Music]
new model army uh although they're
pretty hard
edge right um pj harvey
you know i mean i could i could do a
thing about this someday
uh people who you'd be surprised that
that i i really
like i even like you know some soft rock
stuff like real real soft rock
like christopher cross you know or uh
seals and croft my dad was a big fan of
them
um and i like you know bands like blood
sweat and tears and
things along those lines so um
yeah so those are those are some things
that i really enjoy
there's some some really soft songs i
haven't tried
like calling them to mind oh like you
know seals and crusts i'm a breeze right
i actually play that sometimes so that's
a good thing to end on
glad all of you could join me for
another ama
i didn't get to everybody's questions as
usual but
you know it would be impossible they'd
keep piling up it's that sort of dilemma
of the grains of rice on the uh chess
board right so i hope all of you have a
great month
and um keep studying philosophy
you know and uh uh try to
enjoy yourself remember that the good
that you're doing is still good even if
it doesn't change the world in any sort
of radical ways